well let's talk about what is happening
in Ukraine we're joined by retired Air
Vice Marshall Sean Bell uh Sean good to
see you and just want to talk a little
bit about that story there um are you
surprised that UK officials have
confirmed that Britain's operating in
terms of cyber security for Ukraine
I'm not surprised that we've been
involved in it I am surprised they're
talking about it that's the meat that
the government's announced today
although the timing is interesting with
what else is going in government at the
moment but the Six Million Pound cyber
security program to support Ukraine
defend Ukraine against Russian cyber
attacks these have been conducting huge
numbers before The Invasion but peaked
Around The Invasion time targets for the
Russians include satellites
Communications uh infrast critical
infrastructure around the country what's
particularly interesting I think is that
we've been covering the last couple of
weeks the bombing campaign of Russia ran
critical National infrastructure around
the country looks like the cyber attacks
from Russia have been being conducted on
the same targets for months before that
okay let's talk about what's actually
happening on the ground what can you
update us on today I think story really
is about Return to House and again it's
trying to work out what the Russians
plans is for Harrison we've been
covering whether they're going to stay
in there and fight it out or whether
they're going to withdraw they're
definitely digging defensive positions
around the outside skirts of hairs and
we're not quite sure at the moment where
that's a sign that they're digging in
for the rest or actually that's
providing cover for the withdrawal
because they're actually digging in out
here and here on the sides here but
again it's very difficult to tell the
news though which I think is fascinating
is you look at the Kharkov down out here
which is one of the last remaining
standing Crossing points for the
Russians the Russians have mined this
Dam but increasingly the last couple of
days the Russians have been claimed that
Ukraine ukrainians are targeting it and
firing missiles at it there's absolutely
no benefit whatsoever for Ukraine to
blow that down and flood the river and
flood Harrison well it was far more
likely this is part of a Russian
information campaign trying to blame the
ukrainians whereas in fact they're
planning to blow it which would cover
their withdrawal from Harrison we were
talking yesterday about the partial
mobilization in Russia coming to an end
those 300
000 troops have been recruited but we
found out a little bit more today about
the kind of equipment they're being
given
yeah the mobilization of 300 000 people
it's one thing mobilizing them it's
another thing getting to the front line
which is where Russia critically needs
them they're arriving very quickly
they're with very minimal training now
we're hearing some of them have arrived
without any weapons at all and some of
them arriving with very very old weapons
they're being issued with the um a very
old akm assault rifle which was first
brought into service in the 1950s now it
is the most ubiquitous of the klashnikov
class of weapons but in the 1970s the
Russian serving Army replaced it with
the AK-74 that's got a smaller bullet
what does this matter it matters because
a smaller bullet goes faster takes less
time to get to its Target therefore is
more accurate but clearly they don't
have enough of these 50 year old weapons
to give to the new recruits but it's not
just about the and we're seeing some
footage here recently taken of the
Russian soldiers in Ukraine and actually
for the spotters they'll see that they
are using different forms of rifle but
isn't just about giving the new recruits
old weapons it's actually the fact that
they're now putting two different
weapons into Theater which needs you
mean means you need two different sets
of spare support and crucially two
different forms of ammunition that
creates a logistics nightmare for Russia
uh just at a time when they haven't been
good at that I'm sure winter can't come
quick enough for the beleaguered Russian
army